there are at least 11 different races  Clans and subgroups in the seven deadly  sins including a brand new one that was  only introduced in the sequel we have  regular humans and also Druids a  subgroup of humans who live in nature  and worship the goddesses then we have  Giants fairies vampires and also  beastmen a race of humanoid beasts that  can take on a human form we can't forget  the dark and Powerful demons and the  Angelic goddesses these two races have  been at War for thousands of years but  with the Union of meliodas and Elizabeth  another race was born the Nephilim a  unique Fusion of goddess and Demon there  are also celestials descendants of the  Goddess Clan who reside in the sky  Temple and wise men those wizards of  Billy allowin like Merlin wanna know  more about all these different races and  clans subscribe right now a full video  on all of them is coming soon